allora avevo detto che avrei riportato
sul canale dei giochi che mi sono
piaciuti in passato un sacco e quindi
oggi giochiamo lakeview kevin quello
spiego in breve lakeview kevin è un
casino è veramente un bordello
indescrivibile io sono ciao barbone io
sono questo tizio ok mi ricordo più
comandi qua c'è un tizio che si è
impiccato forse perché aveva messo
dislike ai video che ci sono varie
versioni del gioco e la madonna
iniziamo con il 3 che è veramente
geniale praticamente vi spiego eccoci
qua a perfetta che belli siamo questo
gruppo di persone su quest'isola niente
ci facciamo i fattacci nostri finché non
succederà un qualcosa di orribile perché
posso fare le cose posso prendere gli
oggetti posso prendere il cane lanciare
il cane posso nascondermi dietro gli
alberi bene
ap shanghai lei li scorso è che dove sa
che tu puoi cambiare personaggio tu puoi
usare anche gli altri personaggi non
solo il tuo quindi i tuoi quattro
personaggi per per sopravvivere
credetemi se ve lo dicono riusciremo
neanche con questi quattro bene
la partenza non è delle migliori scusate
parka vacca ma siamo scemi a posso
prendere posso picchiare con la mia
gamba
ve la spiego in breve tra pochissimo
arriverà un mostro a ucciderci tutti
l'obiettivo del gioco è sono riuscito a
prendere un altro in braccio l'obiettivo
del gioco è uccidere quel mostro ha
capito o sono arrivata dall altra parte
grazie a dio sono arrivato qua fa tutto
sto casino perché devo alzare esatto
questo perché al momento giusto
io lo farò cadere ecco aiuto agli
ottenuto dall'atleta quanto veloce porca
vacca
sono ancora vivo ora che devo fare un
casino che fa
è scemo ecco ecco ecco ok resta è
servita non pensavo si facesse così male
attenzione beh l'ho preso adesso è ok lo
schiacciato e morto a no non è morto
[Musica]
nella tosca e veloce adesso di
investirlo con la moto sia perché non è
morto mai nella vita con la moto zia con
la moto o dov'è beh se andrà è quello
che se n'è andato prima vista una roba
sgattaiolare via ragazzi forse non è
morto non è morto aiuto aiuto aiuto
che brutta cosa ho visto forza innesti
lo ora è un e muore mai
come è possibile basta ho finito le le
le cose ma non so se è morto a
est è morto adesso sente di a a mamma mi
è stato più difficile levarsi dalle
balle su tizio che pietro io per fare
sta cosa ai tempi ci ho messo una vita
perché fare ucciderlo un casino l'ho
colpito con mille mille modi diversi
veramente voi non avete per chi conosce
sto gioco sa quanto è difficile va a
cagare va cibo per pesci
basta
[Musica]
ma chi cazzo è questo aiuto mi ha ucciso
né ucciso non è vero gli altri sono
tutti morti cosa sono tutti morti gli
altri perché sono tutti morti non mi fa
cambiare personaggio è pure sono un
idiota
ok sono morti leggermente gli altri non
me ne sono neanche accorto prova a
cantare una canzone tipo c ran non mi
ricordavo ce ne fosse nato però convinto
ce ne fosse solo uno già quello era
difficile ci manca solo che ne arrivi un
altro che poi non è un mostro questo è
un killer non ho idea di come fare a
ucciderlo non ne ho la minima
l'accendino c'è però dovrei riuscire a
dargli fuoco ma comunque non basterebbe
per che sono nella cacca totale pro una
maschera varrà qualcosa perché chi sosta
porta a me l'hai proviamoci magari con
la maschera si caga addosso non c'è è
sparito hai visto che sono uguali a su
come te sono solo un killer
l'ho fatta e uccisa io mi scuso
ahia sono ancora vivo no no ti prego
prego tu il tuo cane i tuoi amici siete
morti anche il cane ma lo pensavo mai
perché ne potesse morire no non mi
ricordò potesse morire anche il cane
niente guardalo
era come faccio a farlo fuori
impossibile basta nel denudarsi
maledizione lo trova un modo per
ammazzare l'altro raga devo capire il
caffè è un ottimo modo per uccidere se
ne bevi tanto casino vi giuro non ho
idea di come e no non è possibile o una
non sono pronto ha già è vero che può
arrivare in qualsiasi momento ragano a
noa fermi agli 8 non mi ha trovato non
mi sta trovando zitti zitti e mi metto
qua aia a mi ha spinto a questa parte su
che mi sono fatto malissimo in quanto
vedo non sto proprio bene però in
compenso sono salvo ecco che culo che
culo
e non è possibile vabbè tieni prendi il
mio camere tuo è prendi il mio cane te
lo regalo non ti piacciono i cani azione
prendi la moto scappa scappa scappa non
sei scappare neanche in moto quanto
idiota
facciamo così mi uso come esca e con
l'altro ci vado vai dove è riuscita a
fottermi sotto ogni punto di vista e
traduttore in casa chelsea ma devi
scendere scendi giorni cari la vita è
bella mi sono fatto malissimo però non
ho assolutamente idea di come ucciderlo
impossibi sono morto morto a prescindere
se sì cosa che faccia cosa devo fare
gago speriamo che qua e meno non mi
trovi con sto d'ore non potrà mai entra
[Musica]
fammi capire male le mie fct attirano no
perché stavo pagando che la metà bassa
ma tu che te frega niente accendino
porca vacca eccolo qua no mi ha dato un
bong ma no no no non è vero
ci manca solo che sia fumato no non è
possibile
cosa è successo lì sono fumato di temi
che trovano accendino per cortesia
eccoli la perfetta perché i miei
personaggi sono andati a fuoco
marina e schiaccia male anzi di più con
la maschera e muori
no sono scemo se lasciate ma è un
bambino tanto non puoi arrivare però
solo non ci può arrivare qua impossibile
o ha sfondato la porta questa che prima
non si apriva non è vero c'è un fucile
ho trovato un fucile city medico a frate
vieni qualche una cosina per te bella e
la scarico aia
oddio sciaia era uscito dalla porta al
contrario vabbè che vuoi far sì che vi
fa
no sono scemo solo chef modo perché sono
un idiota nel cervello nell'anima dai
rega madonna che nervi vabbè raga
infatti c'è euro in testa gioco
infattibile ve lo giuro infatti ma poi
come faccio a sfondare una porta di
collages a questo è un proiettile prin
fucile maledizione saperlo prima
sfondare da porsi perfetto
ok di questo lasci qua entra dentro
santo gesù il fucile lo prendi e locali
chi è carico il fucile ma è
[Musica]
ok
scappa scappa vediamo di non sparare
anche stavolta è sei piccolo a janò a
sparagli nuovo smara li sparagli inutile
essere inutile sparagli va di problemi
nel cervello ma a fuoco maledetto poi
non serve a niente che vada a fuoco
perché tanto si va da nel lago a
mettersi il culo nell'acqua e tutto
torna come prima non serve a niente
il primo tentativo che dovrebbe essere
quello che va peggio è collaudato meglio
invece gli altri a cagare sono t peggio
moto sta al tizio cosa ho fatto
è
[Musica]
no non è vero se andati a fuoco tutti
porca vacca giovani motta ha solo io
sono io
è una soda che il gioco brutto basta da
nasconditi non si sa mai
l'altra è morta come questo si sta
pisciando sotto l'altra è morta l'ultima
mia arma niente neanche così ci ho
provato ma l'edizione però in acqua non
ti raggiunge vabbè tanto ormai sono
morto quindi al suicidio
almeno vestiti vieni qua e ce ne sono
eventi visto all'inizio ce ne sono
cinque ist i giochi questo è il terzo
spero umilmente che il video vi sia
piaciuto nonostante la mia scarsità
anche se all'inizio non ero andato male
quindi ragazzi speriamo sia piaciuto
come se si vivesse quanto mi piace anche
ai social minuto descrizione siamo stati
schiette e noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video beh ragazzi
[Musica]